[Music]
is this your car I saw a picture of you
in a Lamborghini and I was I was like
good god that's a crazy fancy car is
that your car unfortunately not that are
you stealing that car in this moment
that's our in pole I think yeah yeah a
very very kind gentleman from from
Lamborghini let me drive it around for a
couple of days so that was oh and so
they got a the paparazzi arrest got a
picture of you it yeah it wasn't I'm not
to my knowledge but it was a it was
certainly a dream come true a lot of fun
what did you do
I've never driven a car right that cool
that crazy fancy what's it what was it
like what did you do when you're in that
car did you do anything special in it
well it's a bit of a spaceship you know
and you put your foot down and very
quickly you're off so I had to be
careful not to get myself in any trouble
with the law saying that in West
Hollywood we really didn't get up
further than sort of 25 miles an hour
that's my favourite thing in LA is
seeing people with these crazy cars it
can do 180 miles an hour in traffic and
they've got the racing gloves on
and they're in between like a Toyota
Tercel and a Hyundai I love that it's
quite embarrassing yeah you feel of
ironic where did you take it I mean did
you go on any errands in this car lots
of errands drove lots of friends arounds
I I did a bit of a dream come true as
well I drove past the in-n-out burger on
Sunset and had to had to pull in oh look
this is a picture that's is that a
picture you took I say I continued did
you go to the drive-thru in a
Lamborghini yes which wish upon the
second hindsight I probably should have
thought twice about it those the cars
really not designed for the in-n-out
burger drive-thru or vice versa
those idiots right their priorities are
all wrong that's that's my only critique
yeah but it involved me sort of reaching
a sort of few meters up out of the
window to grab a because you're so low
right there probably like up here yes
with your hamburger and french fries and
then the the door is that one of those
weird opening like it's exactly that
yeah
so I love that he'd be good you got it
down